Bruno Daro Emmanuel le disait et il y a
souvent ces campagnes de la part des
Russes contre les civils contre les
centres énergétiques mais là ça
intervient après les annonces d'hier les
Occidentaux qui livreront bien donc des
chars lourds Ukrainiens oui ça peut être
une possibilité une forme de riposte si
vous voulez de la part des Russes après
il faut rester prudent puisqu'on sait
que ce genre quand même de frappe se
prépare quelques jours à l'avance donc
il n'est pas absolument certain qu'il y
ait qu'il y ait un lien mais c'est une
c'est évidemment une possibilité quoi
qu'il en soit quoi canon ces Occidentaux
pour l'instant les Russes restent sur
leur stratégie qui est donc c'est mon
barrement sur des cibles civiles en
Ukraine et donc y compris sur la
capitale pour essayer de démoraliser la
population et essayer de de l'affaiblir
au maximum les Russes qui parlent
d'implication directe des
Occidentaux la France elle s'en défend
d'où cette question sommes-nous devenus
nous occidentaux kobiligérant l'Ukraine
bah écoutez c'est un peu l'éternel débat
qui qui se qui se répète à chaque fois
qu'il y a comme ça une annonce de
nouvelles implication des occidentaux
sur la comédie gérance il faut d'abord
rappeler que c'est pas un concept
juridique et que donc en fait c'est soit
dans la tête des Occidentaux soit dans
la tête de Vladimir Poutine qu'on va
décider à quel moment tel ou tel pays et
que belligérant les Occidentaux disent
qu'ils ne sont pas comme il les gens
puisqu'ils procurent des armes qui sont
ensuite manipulés par des soldats
ukrainiens et l'Ukraine est un pays qui
est agressé donc c'est de la légitime
défense donc il n'y a pas de volonté
d'agression de la Russie d'ailleurs y
compris la ministre française à faire
étrangères Catherine Colonna qui se
trouve aujourd'hui à Odessa à répéter
que la France et l'Europe ne font pas la
guerre à la Russie évidemment côté russe
c'est différent puisqu'on a tout intérêt
à parler évidemment de cobelligérant
c'est et d'implication de plus en plus
grande des occidentaux
le terme cela dit ces jours-ci n'est pas
employé par les par les Russes on parle
d'implication directe et encore ce n'est
pas Vladimir Poutine lui-même ce qui est
certain c'est que ça sert d'une certaine
manière
au narratif qui est servi à la
population russe puisque évidemment
comme les Occidentaux sont de plus en
plus impliqués on peut dire le pouvoir
du Kremlin peut dire Horus vous voyez
c'est bien la preuve que sont les
Occidentaux l'OTAN qui a un plan pour
pour s'en prendre à la Russie donc il
faut tous qu'on sert les coudes autour
de Vladimir Poutine le pays est menacé
et donc presque le pays agressé c'est la
Russie c'est ça qui
qui fait dire à certains en Europe
qu'il faut faire quand même attention et
donc il y a ceux qui disent waouh
l'argument du risque escalatoires il
faut il faut un peu en sortir il y en a
d'autres qui disent attention
cet escalade elle est elle est réelle et
en plus on est en train de servir la
cause de Vladimir Poutine un débat qui
n'est pas prêt de déterminé puisque
alors maintenant les le président
ukrainien lui réclame également des
avions de combat voire des missiles de
longue portée merci beaucoup Bruno